the story about jay leno he says
according to the daily mail i'm in my
heart i knew it was wrong
jay leno apologizes to asians for
decades of jokes
that promoted stereotypes and were made
as recently as 2020.
they say media action network for asian
americans
waged 15-year campaign to end the
remarks
the comedian says at the time he
believed the jokes were harmless
comments continued until last year when
leno cracked about koreans eating dog
meat leno says the apology is not the
result of cancel culture
but a legitimate wrong that was done on
my part
it's amazing i mean that's that's the
gist of it apparently he offended
numerous people on the set of nbc's
america's got talent
quote at the time i did those jokes i
genuinely thought them to be harmless
leno said during a recent video
conference with m-a-n-a-a
i was making fun of our enemy north
korea and like most jokes
there was a ring of truth to them what
wow
wow wait wait wait wait wait he's like i
apologize for making these offensive
statements that were true
they were true wow that i love it
is jay leno actually just you know
taking the piss trolling yeah is he
trolling us
he felt like they were harmless but he
knew in his heart they were they were
wrong
he says i was making he said i genuinely
had them to be harmless
he says i knew they were wrong he says
like most jokes there was a ring of
truth to them
you talk wow i know it was wrong but i
was absolutely right
i'm saying this and it's not like i went
after south korea they still have the
internet
so i wouldn't attack that wow i kind of
feel like did we get may maybe get
punked by jay leno and he's just
laughing all the way to the bank now
like he doesn't care he's retired i
guess
he's super rich he's just trolling like
uh tatyana mcgrath right now he's just
like fake apology i i get it you you
could feel bad about it you know
leno is a typical edgelord if you
remember
his i'm joking he was never no he was
known for
towing the line as much as you could
totally late night
extremely never touched his tonight show
money
every cent he made all in the bank lived
off of his stand-up of money it's
really it's a very well-known fact but
you can't no one called him out for it
so i get that you feel badly about it
but keep it to yourself and make a
donation
you don't have to go out and throw
yourself under the bus
what's his show that he has now it's
about cars or something right yeah i
don't know but i can't believe he said
that
i'd like to apologize for making these
offensive jokes which were true by them
no no so there's another quote he says
whenever we received a complaint there
would be two sides to the discussion
either quote we need to deal with this
or scrum they can't take a joke
too many times i sided with the latter
even when in my heart i knew it was
wrong
leno says the apology was not the result
of pressure from so-called cancel
culture
that has drawn complaints from from
others whose comments came under public
fire for actions or statements
lana said the apology was the result of
a legitimate wrong that was done on my
part you know what man i'm i'm offended
i'm offended right now i think what jay
leno is saying this apology is extremely
racist to my
to my family to the and i i mean this
sincerely
it's patronizing yeah when he makes a
joke about a despotic
you know authoritarian regime in north
korea good
screw him like these are the north
korean communist party or whatever they
call it
kim jong-un these are bad people they
put people in gulags for
thought crime right we do not like the
authoritarian garbage we like the idea
that we can poke fun at each other and
treat each other as equals
because that's what it is if i can make
fun of you you can make fun of me we can
knock each other
down a peg or two we get it it's jokes
right jay leno coming out
he's not doing it he actually cares he
made these jokes recently all of a
sudden now he's trying to act like he's
not
you know being racist or whatever i
actually find what he's doing
to be the racist it's more racist
because he's clumping all
asian people together because he feels
bad about a shooting
where six asian women were killed and he
saw his friend go down for the robot
chicken thing or whatever happened
but he's it's it's the flavor of the
week
yeah this week this is the flavor of the
week i'll tell you what offense what
what
what what i find defense about the whole
thing is that
they only started caring not not even
because of this this event that happened
in atlanta they don't care about that
they care because the tide shifted in
the the woke cult and now they have to
you know move
with the the hive and so that's it they
don't know about what happened they
don't care about the news
all of a sudden they heard oh you're
gonna get in trouble because there's a
protest it says stop asian ain't like oh
okay i'll pretend to care now
i don't think jaleno cares is jay leno
really gonna get in trouble i mean he's
at that
he's at that level of rich where you're
not going to make a dent in it
and i think that there's this i push all
the time
to me there's there's nothing sacred i
can joke about
boulder today i could joke about a
muslim guy
in a racially motivated attack killing a
whole bunch of white people i can joke
about it the media says that's not the
case yeah well i'm not the media i'm a
truth teller
oh no i'm just saying like there's
there's a narrative you know yeah
and i know what the narrative is and we
witness that narrative so i
i think that we take in some of that
group think that even though we have
these beliefs
we still take in the real liberal left
soft we're wrong we need to make the
world a better place
and i get it i've battled with it too
but that's how you know you're good
person because you go
oh should i be doing this and you go
yeah i should because comics
comics deal in negative currency we
attack racism we attack homophobia we
attack transphobia
and we make jokes about all of it right
you said your favorite joke was that
classic chappelle thing from a year and
a half once was my favorite joke
it's a damn but chappelle when he
squinted his eyes and bucked his teeth
yeah like dave chappelle on one of the
biggest comedy specials
only a couple of years ago did a 19 was
it like a 1920s style
stereotypical yeah yeah yeah and was
what was the joke like like it was like
but this is how i feel
yeah and he did the accent he did
everything and
i'm i am so uh grateful to dave
chappelle for doing that joke
it's because well it's because remember
what's his name shane i think shane
gillis is yeah
he he said a word we're not allowed to
say on youtube
but he was accusing other people of
saying these things right he was like
these other people say these bigoted
things like this
and apparently they like some other
times in the show they had done like
asian accents or whatever
like mach ones he loses his job over
this
and he was actually being semi-critical
of other people like he was pointing out
something someone else does
dave chappelle literally did it yeah and
they all just said thank thank you dave
that was very funny
and i'm like okay good yeah look man we
need to be
we need to be able to make fun of other
people i do think that
their limits to reasonable you know good
faith efforts at comedy
like there are some people i think just
try to make everyone offended and not
actually
make any points but those aren't the
funny comics right there's a handful
of really good comics in this world
currently and it's probably 50.
and that's including england and they're
long-winded storytellers but there's
still something
really relevant to the craft that they
do but what we do
it's negative currency we take all this
horrible stuff
and it the end is positive when you come
to a live show which you will or if you
bring us here for a live show on chicago
weekend because i would come for pizza
if it's a cheat day and then when you
have
when you see the way these people laugh
and i'm not talking
giggles like the stuff that i do in new
york in front of the most diverse
audiences in the world
has people holding their stomachs
laughing so it's a negative thing that
has a positive
end i've i've seen jo jo rogan's show
yeah
in philly and he goes after everybody
he's he's really good spirited about it
he's not like it's
you get it i've seen dave chappelle
special and i grew up with george carlin
yeah george carlin has got some spicy
bits to say the least
and people used to cheer and clap for it
because we understood i guess
you know i don't know what changed but
now you've got these puritans
that somehow formed on the left that
just want to cancel
people and the problem is there's this
weird
marriage between establishment media
digital advertising
uh and then when the wokeness cancel
coaching stuff came in
it latched on to this establishment
media
so now because of that all of these
people people like jay leno will just be
like tell me what you want me to say and
i'll say it
that's basically what they're doing so
they're abandoning their principles
or or showing us they never had them to
begin with or they're showing us their
absolute cowards and they don't care to
to actually stand up for true
classically liberal values freedom of
speech freedom of speech
you know progressive thought right yeah
you know you know it's really crazy i
was listening to
um i don't care i was looking at and the
the uh i was listening to that eminem
song
i think it's called without me not
entirely sure that's what it's called
but what's really fascinating about
older eminem music is that
it was very topical and offensive and
controversial so like he's got that line
where he's like you know the grammys try
to bring bring him there and he's like
why because you guys just lied so you
can get me here
sit me here next to brit britney spears
christina aguilera better switch me
chair so i can sit next to carson daly
and
fred durst hear margie over who she to
first you know we'll keep it family
friendly a little bit
but uh that was a popular song where he
was calling out a female pop star
for going down on a couple of other
celebrities
and that was a hit song everybody was
loving it they were laughing it
i guess christina aguilera did a diss
track against them and i'm thinking
about that song where he's like we need
a little controversy it feels so empty
without me
and now we have this story where
apparently like they're trying to cancel
eminem
you know like the gen z has been
complaining about him being a bigot and
stuff and saying offensive things of
course he said offensive things it's
eminem dude we think
yeah and he made a song called like you
know cancel me or something
it's not very good in my opinion but
whatever and i'm just it's it's
interesting now
how much things have changed and how we
have this generation that grew up on
south park on family guy and eminem and
all these shows have become puritans
and then you get like i mentioned the
establishment is scared
they bend the need of the stuff digital
advertising gets scared they bend and
bend the need of this stuff it's a it's
a dramatic transformation in only like
10 years
you know what i mean it is but you're
also aware of
how much ebb there's been and how much
uh the plates have shifted
that you don't really need advertiser
dollars anymore that you can
you can make your own way you look at
you know other comics that have done it
they build their own audience
they go out on their own it's it's meant
to be
controversial if you're not in trouble
you're not
doing anything or saying anything but
they'll try and shut you down
for something totally unrelated if you
if you were
spewing this rant on why you think cove
it wasn't a real thing and that it was
you know to do something else
politically uh
they would disagree with that but they
would try and shut you down for
using a slur for a little person or
something
yeah cuomo gets caught trying to cover
up
the death of 15 000 people due to his
policies
he put sick people in his nursing homes
he was warned by the nursing homes
you're going to kill people and he said
do it anyway
and then they call for his resignation
because a handful of women came out and
accused him of inappropriate behavior
and i'm like you know it's tough do am i
happy
that they're calling for resignation
because he's a bad guy who's got to get
out
or is it bad because it's just the ends
justify the means they ignore the
atrocity
and they're like but don't you slight
women that's it that's it right
people won't come after the thing that
really offends them because they know
that they will lose that argument so
instead they look for these other little
thorns in your side
so it's like if i've done transphobic
jokes or anti-asian jokes
that's what people come after because
they know that the product is oh here's
an
hour of making people laugh hysterically
we can't
argue with that but we can argue with
hey you can't do that asian joke that
you did two years ago
that's what they just want to pick it
and my belief is that people that really
try and
cancel comics is to negate those people
out of the way
to open up have you ever seen woke
comedy yeah
they try and cancel me they'll tag clubs
it's horrible it's i know it's
unwatchable
there was no no but hold on hold on it's
like
it reminds me of uh you watch futurama
have you ever seen futurama i've seen it
so they there's one episode
way back in the day they crash land on
an amazonian planet populated by all of
these massive like 10-foot tall
super-ripped women
that's racist and right right like
sexist
and so the amazonians are explaining how
they have basketball and no can dunk but
good fundamentals
yeah and so like they're they're kind of
making that joke as well that it's like
it's not entertaining to watch but it's
the right
you know but you're so you have to
support it because it's the right
ideology right yeah
so you have these comics it's awful
unwatchable i watched a special from
vice
on what comedy and it was really sad i
saw that it was sad it was the person
making fun of themself the whole time
and i was like dude this is depressing
me dude
like i'm not laughing i feel bad for
this person it's like i'm gonna go out
and i'm gonna like i'm gonna go ride my
bike get exercise because that person
depressed the hell out of me yeah like
hearing them just complain about how
miserable their life
is the old rule is tragedy plus time
they want to take the tragedy away and
just be like
here's the time yeah and it's boring it
is
and and but it's it's it's like
buzzwords
though it's clapter you know yeah like
they'll get up on stage and be like
those white supremacists they're bad
right yeah there's a lot of
white people bashing now i haven't seen
it that much in the past year because
comedy's been either like illegal
and taking place in speakeasy
environments or outdoors
illegal the only real people that have
been doing it are the people that are
ballsy enough to go out and be like hey
i don't care about this thing that
killed 500 000 people allegedly but i'm
gonna go out and uh just do comedy
and that's why the audiences are also
more
right-wing now so they're more willing
to laugh at stuff well they're more
going to come out
yeah this is the crazy thing so we had a
chrissy
mayer yeah i watched you know yeah and
um
i think she brought this up for the
subject came up where you have all of
these leftists
who are scared of covet they don't want
to go out all of these urban
environments where they've shut
everything down because of covid
so what's left conservatives are willing
to come to your show
not necessarily conservatives but people
who aren't scared are willing to come to
your show right and you can do it in
more conservative areas in red states
where they didn't lock everything down
so these left-leaning individuals or
whatever you want to call it
corporate democrat types politically
sheep whatever are in their apartments
doing nothing
not going out comedy clubs are being
shuttered and then comedians are
doing jokes for conservatives yeah you
know where you're more where you
actually have your
your business still exists think about
what's going to happen when when all
this finally gets lifted and who knows
when it'll get lifted for the blue
states because the red states are
already opening up
they're going to be stunted by like a
year market-wise
you are going to have way more
conservatives with savings
with money because they're in business
yeah they're going to get a year advance
on all of these left-wing
you're going to get a bunch of liberals
working for conservatives they're going
to need a job and
who's going to own the jobs the
conservatives yeah and you go online
all the conservative comics are like hey
i'm in omaha this weekend hey i'm here
this weekend hey i'm here
all the liberal comics are like when's
that stimmy coming through
and they're just waiting for that stimmy
and they still call it stimmy i don't
know so
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time